1783 and the Americans have left the
Empire led by King George the third
famous for being crazy now had to find a
new place for a penal colony and it
found one in Australia so both Australia
and New Zealand had been known to
Europeans for centuries because of past
Dutch explorers it was Captain James
Cook who sailed to both and claim them
for Britain New South Wales was chosen
as Britain's new penal colony in the
first convicts arrived in 1788
so in the next year the French
Revolution happened paving the way for
the Napoleonic Wars which were a British
victory victory here gave Britain a few
new colonies such as Malta and South
Africa importantly it also weakened
Britain's great imperial rival meaning
it could increase the size of his empire
without much resistance which it did the
century following the Napoleonic Wars is
known as the Pax Britannica
the British Peace in which Britain was
the world's sole superpower over the
next few decades Britain which Islands
had formally been incorporated into
seized Guiana Singapore Assam and this
territory in India Britain was helped in
these ventures by the East India Company
who oversaw Britain Strait with China
mostly in opium China had previously
banned opium but Britain refused to
listen and kept importing it anyway
because money in 1839 the Imperial
Chinese government seized opium from
British ships and destroyed it which led
to armed conflict which Britain won
gaining lots of money a continuation of
opium selling in Hong Kong Britain's
victory here also gave it huge influence
over China's economy bringing it into
what is known as the informal Empire the
informal Empire consisted of places
which weren't directly under British
control but due to military and
diplomatic pressure were often coerced
into acting in Britain's interests to
the northwest of India Britain turned
its eyes to Afghanistan on the surface
this was for trade but the major reason
was Russia Britain was afraid that
Russia would seize either Afghanistan or
Persia from which he could then invade
India Britain was also worried that
Afghanistan would make an alliance with
Russia and so invaded this was a
complete disaster and amounted to
nothing more than a slaughter of British
and Indian troops by the Afghan militias
this competition for influence between
Britain and Russia is known as the great
game and spread beyond Asia and into
Europe the Russians were increasing
their influence in the Balkans and
Britain was worried about Russian
dominance there as well in order to curb
Russia Britain France and the Ottoman
Empire began the Crimean War which was a
victory for the Allies and slowed the
growing Russian power in North America
Canada was established as a province and
the borders between itself and the US
were finalized
Canada later gained autonomy by becoming
a Dominion which meant that the colony
was self-governing but foreign policy
was left to Britain also about this time
the British began to settle New Zealand
at first the Maori the natives of New
Zealand were fine with Europeans as they
brought trated them but eventually it
dawned on them that the Europeans
weren't going to stop coming this led to
war which the British won leading to
more European settlement in contrast to
populating New Zealand Ireland faced one
of the greatest D populations in human
history thanks to the potato famine
which decimated potato harvests the
British forced the Irish to grow cash
crops which meant that there was less
space to grow food there the Irish grew
potato since he had such a high caloric
yield for the space litre cup when the
famine struck it was made worse by the
British government who ordered the food
would still be exported from Ireland to
Britain and the aid would be limited
Ireland's population dropped by half and
still he's yet to recover to its pre
1800 levels all the way back in India
Britain specifically the independent
East India Company was having some
trouble so background the East India
Company's military was mostly staffed by
set boys who were Indian troops who
served under British officers these set
boys became increasingly unhappy as
their treatment worsened their pay
stagnated and they were also forced to
fight abroad despite British promises
that they wouldn't have to British
policy in India had also led to massive
changes in its society as well which
upset many of those living there for
example the British levied heavy taxes
and did nothing to protect the Indian
textile industry
the British were also arbitrarily
grabbing more and more territory which
understandably made some Indian rulers
nervous furthermore the British were
also keen proselytizers and many Hindus
and Muslims felt the British wanted to
convert all of India to Christianity
none of this endeared the British to the
Indians and in 1857 the set boys
revolted against the East India Company
one set boy could Mangal Pandey mutiny
against the British by assaulting some
officers and his execution made him a
martyr the earlier British defeat in
Afghanistan also gave confidence to the
Indian since it meant that the British
could be defeated the actual rebellion
began when Indian troops were issued
with ammunition coated in either pig or
beef fat which offended both the Muslim
and Hindu suppose when they refused to
use the ammunition the British arrested
them and they alongside others knew to
need the rebelling said boys seize some
cities including Delhi but eventually
the British were able to defeat them the
reasons for this were there only a few
Indian states actually joined the
rebellion many were neutral and support
for the British remained strong one
reason for this was that the concept
being Indian didn't really exist India
is an exceptionally diverse place and a
Muslim from Bengal or a Sikh from Punjab
had little in common with a Hindu from
Delhi another reason for the rebellions
failure was that it was not a
pre-planned politically backed up rising
in the British had much better
organization the cost incurred in money
prestige and lives led the British crown
to take control of the running of India
and the East India Company was dissolved
in 1858 and Queen Victoria was
proclaimed the Empress of India the
British also gained more land from the
Indians removing disloyal Chiefs called
now abbs from power
Britain's dominance over its colonies
was secured by increasing technological
advancements brought about by the
Industrial Revolution some of the most
important of these advancements for the
steam powered ship trains the telegram
and more advanced firearms this
dominance wouldn't last forever and
towards the end of the century Britain
found itself with new rivals these were
the United States which was recovering
from its Civil War the newly unified
German Empire and arising Japan which
was looking to carve up Asia the new
German Empire wanted colonies of its own
and so turned to Africa this worried the
British and in order to soothe tensions
the Berlin conference was called to
divide up Africa in a way that avoided
war so Africa went from looking like
this to this with Britain and France
getting the lion's share so the British
public's response to imperialism was
mixed outright opposition to colonialism
was very rare most people's attitudes
sat between apathy and a deep pride in
Britain's role as a colonial power this
was primarily due to the belief that
Britain was a civilizing force so
Britain's conquest of Africa was not as
simple and straightforward affair
Britain had substantial military
advantages and for the Africans it was
conquering such as rifles machine guns
and gunboats yet many Africans were able
to win victories against the British
such as the Zulus who slaughtered the
British at the Battle of Isandlwana
on the same day the British won one of
its best battles the Battle of Rorke's
drift another group of Africans the
Boers who were originally Dutch settlers
also resisted British expansion in South
Africa in order to defeat boa guerilla
warfare by denying them shelter the
British place many women and children
into concentration camps where they
faced horrible conditions the conquest
of Africa was short and was pretty much
complete after 30 years with only
Ethiopia and Liberia remaining
independent the southern colonies in
Africa were unified into South Africa
which alongside Australia and New
Zealand became a Dominion just like
Canada the Empire grew to its
territorial height after
first world war where Britain gained
sizable Ottoman and German territory it
wasn't all gains for Britain those
throughout the war Britain's Holden
Island became untenable and Ireland
became an independent republic in 1922
from the crumbling Ottoman Empire the
British gained Palestine which it was
decided would become a home for the
world's Jewish people hundreds of
thousands of Jews arrived in Palestine
over the next couple of decades and
their increasing numbers and political
powers their cause several revolts
against the British all of which were
suppressed after the Second World War
many more arrived and the tensions rose
again culminating in a civil war and the
creation of Israel so the Second World
War was a British victory but her
brought Britain to the brink of economic
ruin Indians had been seeking
independence from Britain since about
five minutes after it turned up many
Indians felt that their contribution to
both world wars men that they were owed
independence in 1937 India held
elections in which the Indian National
Congress an advocate for independence
won the largest share of the seeds
furthermore the famine of 1943 which was
caused mostly by Britain diverting food
away from India had cost the lives of
many millions increasing demands for the
end of British rule the most famous
opponents to the British were Mohandas
Gandhi and Muhammad Ali Jinnah Gandhi
was not a politician but was very
important since he practiced a
nonviolent approach Jinnah is famous for
advocating that India be divided so that
Muslims could have their own state as
well in 1947 India gained its
independence and was subsequently
divided into India and Pakistan Britain
was unable to fight this tide due to its
weakness it simply couldn't afford to
force India to stay furthermore Clement
Attlee Britain's post-war prime minister
was sympathetic to the Indian cause the
division of India was not so peaceful
though and it is believed that during
the mass migration ethnic cleansing and
fighting this occurred afterwards as
many as 2 million people died in the
aftermath of World War 2 Britain found
itself opposed by two anti imperialist
superpowers the United States and the
Soviet Union slowly but surely over the
course of the 20th century colonies
broke away from British rule some
violently some peacefully a notable
example of British imperial retreat is
Kenya Kenya had been run similarly to
most other colonies with white settlers
owning lots of land amassing wealth and
forcing horrible working conditions on
the natives many Kenyans notably Jomo
Kenyatta
attempted to get reforms from the
British all of which were refused some
Kenyans then turned to violence and what
is known as the Mau Mau uprising began
the Mau Mau resorted to guerrilla
warfare
British were able to suppress the
uprising after capturing its leaders
both sides committed horrendous war
crimes including torture and the murder
of women and children in 1960 Britain
announced that it would move towards an
independent Kenya and in 1963 can you
gain its independence with Kenyatta as
its first president
Britain's motives of this was simple the
writing was on the wall and the Empire
was going to end
Harel Macmillan the Prime Minister of
Britain made sure that the handover of
power was swift to help promote good
relations between Britain and its former
colonies decolonization would continue
for the next several decades until
Britain's last major colony Hong Kong
was handed back to China in 1997 thus
marking the end of the Empire so in
conclusion the legacy of the British
Empire is undeniable one only needs to
look at a map of countries that drive on
the left play cricket or rugby or still
have the British monarch as the head of
state
opinions on the Empire range from it
being a civilizing force to an
oppressive one what can be said for
definite is that without the Empire the
world would have looked very different
today I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching
you